a police shooting in grand rapids
michigan is renewing questions about
de-escalation tactics the video of this
incident we have to tell you is
extremely disturbing 26-year-old patrick
leoyea was killed after resisting and
running away during a traffic stop
he and the officer wrestled over the
taser before leo was shot in the head
while lying face down on the ground with
the officer on top of him adriana diaz
is in grand rapids she's been following
this story from the beginning adriana
good morning every time people look at
the video the question is whether no
other option here
that's exactly right now gail you saw
the video the situation escalates in a
matter of mere minutes so that key
question is should the officer have
acted differently to de-escalate based
on his training we looked up the grand
rapids police policy and it states that
an officer should always try to control
a situation using verbal commands but if
a suspect does not comply only then can
the officer escalate to use physical
force the amount of force should be
quote reasonable and based on the level
of resistance encountered now in terms
of de-escalation the policy only says
that as the subject begins to
de-escalate or lessen the resistance
offered the officer must de-escalate in
a similar manner now for clarity we
spoke to a criminal procedure professor
here in michigan who also happens to be
a former detective with the state police
his name is louis langham and we asked
him we said did the officer act in line
with this policy here's what he said
there was substantial compliance to that
policy based upon what was taking place
the verbal commands given by the officer
they were ignored and it escalates up
from there i didn't see
um any major problems with the officer's
actions necessarily as it relates to
whether or not he did what he was
supposed to do for the most part in
trying to control the situation without
using any type of
excessive force or or violence and then
things obviously got out of control
protesters and the family attorney ben
crump say it was the officer who
escalated the situation some of the
community that we spoke to last night
said police need not only more
de-escalation training but also more
mental health and diversity training now
this officer is on paid administrative
leave while the michigan state police
investigates the incident then the kent
county prosecutor will look at the
findings from that investigation to
determine if any charges are warranted
gail
adriana what have we heard from mr
leoyea's family
gail we spoke to them yesterday and
the family is broken the mother was
crying throughout the press conference
we sat down with the family afterwards
and this family moved to the u.s from
the democratic republic of congo in 2014
they fled war there they're refugees and
the father told us we left
our country to come to america for
safety and he said he cannot imagine
that this has happened here he said my
son was killed like an animal the family
wants prosecutors to charge this officer
to the fullest extent of the law gail
all right adriana diaz reporting thank
you